i don't uh support their marriage she's
so cool
yeah and he's not adam levine objects
that's all i want to say during an
appearance on the ellen degeneres show
thursday the 42 year old maroon 5 front
man was asked about his pals blake
shelton
and gwen stefani getting hitched and in
true adam fashion
he used the opportunity to take a jab at
the country singer
i don't uh support their marriage she's
so cool
yeah and he's not he's not cool
he's he's but he's very funny and very
smart he
is vaguely charming
i miss this i missed making so much fun
of him
as for the couple's big day adam said
he'll be in attendance
i'll go to the wedding and i'll object
yeah i will probably not be invited now
but i'm saying this on live television
but i'll be there during a december
appearance on late night with seth
meyers
blake said that he plans to have the
sugar singer perform at his wedding
i've kind of decided that uh
you know i've been doing this a long
time now and i've got a lot of favors
out there and
and he may not like it but adam levine
going gonna have to to get
the band together and and come and play
our wedding
and in march adam responded to all that
during a chat with the morning mash-up
he's like yeah he's like i'm gonna get
adam levine to come play
he doesn't know it yet and i'm like
sitting there in bed like eating popcorn
and i'm like
[ __ ] you i might come to play your way
yeah something tells me he'll do it
i would like to think so last week gwen
shared some details about her upcoming i
do's on late night with seth meyers
and she said she wants to keep the whole
thing low-key
it's incredible to have a best friend
like that guy
i think he's probably very simple really
simple
i think that the guest list will not
have a lot of musicians is going to be
like my mom and my dad
like just literally going to be just
family
and we are looking forward to that
though as for blake
ichi caught up with the 44 year old
singer earlier this month
and he opened up about being nominated
for an academy of country music award
alongside gwen at this year's ceremony
for their song
nobody but you looking in your eyes now
i texted her actually uh this morning on
the way here
i wish she was here with me and uh and
there was something on
social media or twitter that that
narville my manager
forwarded to me and said look at this
you know and i s and i texted her
that whatever that was and i said i
can't believe
that i get to be nominated for awards
with my best friend you know and it was
just one of those moments it's like
how do you get so blessed and so lucky
you know